est-ce que tu as bien gagner ta vie tu
gagnes attali est ce que tu es un
flambeur j'ai été flambeur ah ouais
c'est vrai ce genre ouais j'ai été formé
aux amitiés parce que j'ai toujours tout
partagé
ce combat mais j'étais un vrai flambeur
au jeu ouais à céret ouais c'était un
vrai flambeur à la roulette à richardson
riches parce que je peux plus comme je
passais ma vie à donner mon argent à un
pas à partager avec tout le monde un
changement s'il faut que je trouve un
truc où je dépense mon argent que pour
moi et c'est vrai et je me suis mis et
c'est vrai que la roulette c'est
passionnant mais j'ai arrêté comme
l'alcool j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté tout
seul j'ai une technique qui consiste à
dire que quand les emmerdements dépasse
le plaisir tu t'arrêtes mais c'est pas
des emmerdements de perdre c'est
fascinant la roulette c'est
extraordinaire mais voilà un moment j'en
ai eu marre mais j'ai été flagellé folie
jour un truc que tu acheté un jouet un
truc de fou et non non non c'est pas
puis je suis pas un mec de blé si j'en
ai beaucoup je suis content je suis
comme tout le monde si j'allais beaucoup
je suis content mais je pense pas quand
je monte sur scène je pense pas exclue à
ce que je vais gagner quoi j'aime le
confort voilà j'aime bien le confort pas
le luxe mais le confort comme tous les
gens qui ont manqué quand il était temps
qu'ils étaient là je pourrais m'arrêter
là je pourrai me dire à la retraite mais
c'est pas ça moi ce qui m'intéresse et
je fais des trucs qui rapporte de
l'argent et des trucs qui rapportent pas
quand je fais du théâtre ça rapporte
moins là le bouquin l'aller ça fera pas
un best seller mais ça me passionne
c'est le magazine que je fais tous les
deux mois c'est c'est tenter de vivre
des choses et puis on en parlait que mon
vieux norbert justement faut vivre les
choses les vivre bien après le reste att
c'est au contraire très fière nantes un
flambeur non j'ai devant moi j'ai
partagé j'aimais bien la roulette ou à
roulettes fabuleux la houle à lui lui
c'est un malade je n'ai pas malade mais
chez titi la roulette oui assez
diabolique la houle et moi j'ai fermé
une table j'ai tellement gagner à la
roulette qu'il faut fermer la table à
quel endroit à monaco tag est jolie
sportive qu'ils ont fermé la table mais
c'est la table en deuil
sa femme
[Applaudissements]